hi I can explain give me a chance I can
tell you why I'm playing this game first
off this is blush blush this is a game
that is an idol game which means it's
like cookie clicker you let money just
kind of generate for you and you use
that to unlock better ways to make more
money it's an endless game like that but
it's also a dating game you just so
happen to be dating guys that have
somehow transformed into animals all
right now I'm gonna stop you right there
I'm gonna stop you right there because
you're judging you need to allow me to
explain myself this is very important
that you listen closely otherwise you're
gonna go off on assumptions and you're
gonna assume things about me and this
game that don't necessarily make sense
no second thing apparently I'm in the
game now on its surface level you could
say like yeah that kind of looks a bit
like wait I I mean I need to put my
glasses you can kind of be like oh well
you know there's a bit of a resemblance
but it's not necessarily mark you know
there's only a passing resemblance this
seems kind of ridiculous it goes even
deeper because you have to look at I
think the wiki that shows quotes from
this character and I don't know about
you but that quote there that seems like
me now you may be thinking also okay
hold on I know you're assuming something
else but what did we just talk about
assuming things let me explain this I
didn't know about this in any way shape
or form I did not know that I was in
this game and for all intents and
purposes I'm not that's just Janeiro
youtuber person with colored hair they
have blue eyes I don't have blue eyes
they're 6 feet tall I'm not 6 feet tall
[Music]
anyway so it's probably not me but to
get to the bottom of this mystery I need
to find out exactly if that's me and the
only way I can get to that proof and the
truth is by getting getting to the point
where I can date myself this isn't just
an exercise in narcissism this is uh
this is an investigation I'm a private
investigator
so let's date soon furries looks like
NIM just wants a refund for it wave a
hand I don't know what's happening here
I I haven't paid attention to the game
since I loaded it up looks like NIM just
wants a refund for his zoo admission
sounds reasonable for that you're gonna
need a job tap on the jobs tabs so I've
been turned into a rabbit that's new yes
new is definitely the word for it I
don't know why I would want to see you
all right is that me Wow interesting
let's see this all right so that's part
of me right no nice hat some sweet glass
Sue's not mustache love it nice bag
we're just making morph stash here
bowtie yes okay that's all we get that's
better actually I like that better okay
so all right let's get to it
hobbies achievement hair-raising Oh
reach acquaintances reach frenemy
friend-zoned awkward besties crush
sweetheart boyfriend lover max lover
level I've only heard rumors about max
lover level am i a cat
that's the one in question this is gonna
be hard cuz I have to play through this
whole game to get to it so memory album
no no reminisce I don't wanna you know
what I'm good pass hard pass alright
store no store don't work I don't get to
the store
Oh store don't work okay alright that's
good woah most of them are locked right
now I guess you're not qualified yet
each job takes time blocks to do and you
only have a few to spare
don't worry once you turn them off you
get your time blocks back alrighty
seamstress so good great you'll be able
to afford that refund in no time there's
one more hot tip for jobs if you keep
the job active for long enough you learn
promotions which means more money in
your pocket being employed rules
having a job is the best I sure love
getting a salary my pension plan just
gives me joy let's go back to NIM ok
good now that you've got money flowing
and I'll teach you about hearts why do I
have to work for these sorry sacks of
poop that got turned into animals you
can give it hearts by chatting receiving
giving gifts dating and even by just
tapping on the guy a whole bunch chat
with them with the talk button then give
him a bunch of tapi taps what what what
what hi there hi I'm not usually a
rabbit
I'm not sure why but I felt that was
important to be upfront about cool Oh No
[Music]
ok alright here we go
there we go that's what I'm talking
about
what do these do I'm not oh I'm not sure
if it's working I understand if you're
out of the shake hands and part ways now
it seems like a lot of trouble you'll
keep trying great thanks for sticking
with me I am one appreciative Bunny you
know for someone that was just turned
into a bunny you wouldn't usually refer
to yourself as that oh I heard diamond
up your smart stat and taken to dinner I
got to be intelligent enough to take him
out to dinner I can't figure out where
that [ __ ] is I don't know where the
restaurant is I don't even know how to
pay you expect me to calculate tip with
my level of brain I did dream last night
that it turned back into a human but
then I got ready for the day and went to
work before I woke up so that's a three
out of ten would not recommend I'm just
gonna keep doing this cuz really good at
tapping hobbies never mind whoo each
hobby works on improves Oh a top you
work on improves one of your stats they
each take three time blocks to do so
once again you'll need to use your time
wisely fortunately you've got enough to
do some reading which will make you
smart activate your reading hobby while
you're working on that make sure you
have some free time blocks and we'll
take NIM on a date you can tell them
anytime blocks you'll have and how many
are in use at the top of your screen
here they're color-coded for your
convenience green means jobs orange
means hobbies and pink means dates
all right so I gotta stop making money
to go on a date and that sounds about
right actually
dinner ah that's nice
that's real nice go again what did
dinner what don't moan don't groan just
don't do that why would you do that
alright finder the chef to prepare me a
fancy keratin of the waiter to try and
scratch out the word Hasenpfeffer oh
that means rabid donuts enjoyed myself
you're blushing why are you blushing
because it
is this it is this the reason you're
blushing oh no no no tickle in the bunny
I know it's hard but resist the
temptation don't know luck do you have
anything else to break the curse do we
need I don't know a magical sword or a
quest or something I'll give you a
magical sword all right well then I'm
glad for that at least I've never been
on a quest but I have a sneaking no I
earned a diamond I'm gonna memorize this
one I'm shooting it into my brain
through my eyeballs I dug in my own
garden yesterday and built a den a
Warren whatever rabbits build this got
to really suck when you get swooped up
by a hawk and then just dead it's like
oh [ __ ] I should have clicked harder oh
god no yeah I really wish that I
actually helped you but I'm not gonna
frenemy more like more please why are we
friend of me that doesn't even make
sense I'm gonna status no tickling the
bunny Oh wink whatever fine survival why
do I need to survive don't you [ __ ]
do that ever again don't you do I'm not
here for you I'm here for someone else
who this is a lot of things to do this
is a lot of things to do I'm starting to
realize how daunting this task is but
it's gonna be worth it because we need
to get to the bottom of this mystery I
need three more time blocks no I don't
go away can I go to the step oh the
store does exist oh well I gotta earn me
some diamonds well I'll give me some
diamonds Oh My gods to get all that's
the best deal okay I got to get ten
diamonds no 80 diamonds ah oh I'm gonna
get that that's gonna be my objective
cuz that's a good deal because five
times 15 is 75 and that's way cheaper
than 50 and then 10 times 15 is 150 and
that's 78 diamond savings lone-wolf oh
hi Oh Oh God Oh God well on the forest
right seen your survival training you're
attacked out of nowhere by a sharply
dressed bear before she can land a super
sick burn a wolf suddenly intervenes
okay
after a ferocious battle the wolf drives
the bear away and looks at you with
intense brooding eyes as he licks his
wounds he scoffs oh it's you
well don't get too excited that bear and
I just had some unfinished business why
are you looking at me like that with
that weird gleam in your eye don't tell
me you're gonna keep bothering me Oh F
my L hey I wasn't too far off
[Laughter]
Jhoanna wolf all my boyhood dreams have
come true do that I was such a nice
little kid
you mean dumbass like this hey I got a
time slot when did I get that hey sweet
you earned them for free about this what
I'm gonna get you hey I got some guts
you like him
pretty cool right now let's go to dinner
twice yeah let's do this
what salad you don't like it I got a
nice rabbit for you
Hasenpfeffer like Hasenpfeffer do you
like hot send ever Oh
let's go again Oh to YouTube whatever
shut up I tried really hard at this it's
the same place I'm taking all these
animals the waitstaff cannot be ok with
this by the way I just realized the
waitstaff not only did they give the
best table of all tables to this strange
bear but they're willing to serve us
that was terrible the salad wasn't even
the worst part he was that waiter that
kept asking why wasn't hungry like the
wolf I'm glad I bit him huh I hate you
for making me laugh I didn't ask for
your help but if you want to waste you
down bothering me I guess I can't stop
you does this mean I'm stuck with you
for now well at least part of being
turned into a wolf is in the worst part
of this anymore
mmm if you see that bear again just ask
her what you do with all the puppies or
last lover butter the awkwardness will
drive her off oh god no I don't like
that I like that I don't like that very
healthy
I like healthy let's get me some healthy
level 4 healthy how am I gonna get level
4 healthy I don't even know what that
means
mm-hmm huh
seed gift its head take some seed there
you go how did you know exactly what I
had craving for it's like you could see
into my mind and read from a list of
requirements I had spooky sure we're
gonna go on a boat ride you like boats I
bet you like a boat see look ducks you
don't kill ducks do you see I'm not yet
to the point where I'm completely
questioning what I'm doing here I still
feel like I'm justified in this and you
guys are along with me for the ride now
you have to now that you've gotten to
this point you have contractually
obligated yourself to continue it to the
end that's just how it goes I'm sorry
I've literally never spent so much time
with someone else before so are we gonna
keep trying tomorrow great I mean I
don't want to tackle this alone but I'm
sure you're busy so this works for me
all right my word the world is not built
for rabbits have you ever tried opening
a pudding cup with your paws I want
pudding so bad okay what are you doing
I'm not using my time correctly am i
give me some money well this is just
what I'm doing now so that's too many
hearts I don't even feel like it Oh I
ate a bowl of tricks oh you can just
talk to him oh that's that's so much
better
oh don't loan don't grumble don't groan
oh you can reset oh yeah like new game+
i knew that was a part of idle games
I've always been a fan of that
interesting look at that [ __ ] ball on
your quest to find all the transformed
buoys you decide to look in the ocean
but it turns out that being in water is
the leading cause of drowning and you
begin to sink you yell for help
and a lifeguard rushes to your rescue
pulling you from the briny deep
ha gotcha he says in a dramatic fashion
rest easy
you'll safe now sorry it took me more
than four seconds to save you I'm only
half the lifeguard out once wolves
that's when you notice that your
lifeguard is an enormous chicken that's
when you would notice that the lifeguard
was an enormous [ __ ] it's one of the
guys you cursed looks like this is your
chance to save them rescue yeah
that's your vote no that's not your
voice hey hey wow it looks like you got
lots to do and not a lot of time you
need more time blocks you're in time
blocks from achievements one time block
for every five achievements you can also
buy them with a store with diamonds here
I'll show ya Wow
here's what happens since your loveable
I'll give you a freebie oh there you go
there are lots of super cool boosts and
stuff to buy in the store so take a look
around enjoy right okay cool great I've
got more time blocks yes yeah so you
think you can help honestly I just
appreciate the effort they were less in
his helpful at the hospital telling me I
should see a specialist at the KFC well
why would I be so bad that's stupid
screw you
hey you want some veggies I bet you do I
bet you do I bet you do I'm more money I
need more money that's what you sound
like stupid alright I'm gonna take you
on level six healthy alright let's go to
dinner
that's it right yeah that's him right
now what do you have butt cheeks on your
neck look at that he's got butt cheap
Nick don't bill me look they took Hopsin
feather off the menu for the rabbit I
can't listen it might not be chicken it
might be duck I'd be fine right why do
you care I guess you should care I
probably care I wonder what I'll care
about when I find myself I did it did I
do it level six healthy I'm just so used
to ordering the chicken it's clean
protein delicious what a disaster how's
your fault not mine yeah it's too bad
play blush blush for one day three days
one week one month a year who's gonna do
that who the hell would do that I
wouldn't do that I'm not gonna that's
gum this is my life now Hey look at that
what neck what neck unless those are a
sweet pair of tits
[Applause]
I've been posed he/she had to help you
seem pretty stand up publish them really
ready to deal with being a chicken but
I'm ready to buckle down and fix this
okay
except I just really wish you could have
turned me into something a little less
edible Wow I got a diamond oh yeah so
I'm out I see I'm a mom too I'm a
rooster
but this chicken ain't calling in sick
that's not how this chicken rolls I've
officially said the word chicken too
much all right whatever
look I can't afford a coaster oh I can't
I can't afford a coaster okay I can
afford it we're going on a coaster going
on a coaster wahoo
wait reach max lover level with NIM wait
did I reach max lover level when did I
reach max lover level once I helped did
I when did I reach max lover level what
oh my oh my I um I maybe will sit out
the next ride I mean I'm sure there's
probably a rule about rabbits and
rollercoasters that were unaware of but
are safe than sorry
oh no I just got a click on you a whole
bunch don't I well whatever here we go
banker nothing to about to do it I got
to reach max lover level apparently I
don't know how I did that but thanks
love her level indeed why am I doing
this I know I'm doing this you know why
I'm doing this there's a mystery afoot
and I'm gonna solve it yeah I'm gonna
solve it I'm gonna solve it yeah that's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna solve it
but did not you say that in order to
break the curse you want to try a kid
what I didn't say what oh well sure I
mean it's for the medicinal purposes
right I guess we can give it a try so we
have to kiss well okay I mean it's for
medicinal purpose you lean in for a
smooch and there's suddenly a shower of
sparkles and bubbles transforming the
rabbit into mostly not a rabbit progress
hey look at that that's horrifying
that's awful
whoa that's awful I keep looking down
and realizing that I'm mostly human
again now that is definitely a unique
relief to experience all right look I
bet this radish into the shape of a
heart what a coincidental coincidence
care for a bite nope I'm good ah what
happened where am i great karaoke SPCA
volunteer and gaming I'm a gamer
look at me gaming I wonder at what point
it would be better to get a bonus I
wonder at what point it would be better
to get a bonus because I need it I need
to find the most I'm good at clicker
games I am but this this has time gating
stuff here that I can't get around oh
well nothing to it but to do it I guess
boat ride huh well I can't afford that
cuz I am poor all right what am i doing
for the next one outgoing okay let's
just focus on outgoing after these all
roll over roll over
let's talk hey how you doing okay I got
this let's focus on outgoing let's get
some money rolling I don't have time
blocks well let's get that moola going
oh guts and healthy oh I didn't realize
these had oh the same requirements for
getting ah interesting okay it's time to
buckle down and get serious about this
I've been real lackadaisical but by now
you know that you're in this for the
long haul
and let me tell you this is going to be
a long haul so just sit down
go up and get ready because it's going
to be a long haul hey what did I get
made duster who only requires one block
it doesn't make a lot of money but it
only takes one time block well that's
great
I needed something like that just to
bide my time and it'll get promoted
quickly that's great that's just like I
always have that on kind of deal huh
what did I get I got more time I don't
know what I did what did i do Weaver
fever does I mean I don't know i don't
think i reached match max lover level i
got mistaken for a shuttlecock yesterday
and we got whacked around for a set i
feel like there's a joke in there
somewhere but I've got several
concussions and I'm not on my a game
that's hilarious
all right bow ride time all right what
you're gonna eat those ducks oh no
you're shaking off water I thought you
were about to eat those ducks all right
we have made no progress and we've made
next no progress on getting to the end
of this I might I might have to put some
money into this I'm not saying I have to
there's no reason that anybody has to
put money into a free-to-play game that
defeats the purpose what because I have
an objective and it's gonna take a long
long time to get to it I might have to
do that let me just go a little longer
without it but let me let me just be
like I might have to do that bonus maybe
that would be worth it I don't know at
what point is it diminishing returns I
really don't know are your ears red I
don't like that why are your ears
engorged and I went in 3-2 last night I
crept to your window and contemplated
mauling you but knowing my luck you've
probably loaded with gluten or something
so he's really really your concern is
the gluten in me I recommend you figure
out I break back I recommend how you
figure out how to break that curse
sooner rather than later sorry my voice
is weird for a second reach the next
stage with Volks among the blossoms
folks gives you a rare smile
all right all right don't get all
touchy-feely on me you're good people
now get out of my bubble all right hey
it's me again looks like your progress
is slowing way down luckily I've got the
trick to the stats tab see this section
called reset well it resets your game
but in exchange you get a big speed
boost called your
boost this will make the next
playthrough way faster all your dates
jobs and hobbies get sped up big-time
your reset bonus grows every time you go
up a relationship level with a guy so
longer you wait the better the bonus if
you're set now you'll double your speed
the next time you play and don't worry
your time blocks and diamonds won't be
affected I'm not that mean when you feel
ready go for it
maybe I should maybe maybe you're right
about something there you know what I'm
gonna do it I'm doing it screw you oh oh
oh god what have I done
oh god no oh yeah I actually get to see
what the hell happened okay widespread
panic with your reckless water
disbursement what's with a distinct
sense of deja vu
you were filled you'll fill the
determination what oh god no oh god no
alright I gotta get a job
apparently oh that is much faster oh
that is much faster what did you just
say to me yeah oh the dates go faster
too oh yeah I bet like towards the end
of it the diminishing returns of that or
like the exponential growth of the time
horizon would be absurd at a certain
juncture emoji level too smart you're
gonna see haha you're gonna see you're
gonna see I'm gonna show you you're
gonna see all right total bonus 0.01
well that's nothing all right whatever I
gotta give me some good hey hey what's
going on oh so good just cuz you're such
a Baca issue doesn't mean I like you it
is much faster I get it now like I get
is much faster it is faster and I like
that and I'm gonna have to reset this a
lot to be able to get to the end I'm
hoping that I don't have to put money in
it I shouldn't have reset I shouldn't
have reset it's it's what it was a trap
cuz like I'm not getting as much bonus
as I was before at these certain levels
so it was clearly a trap there you are I
found you your rooster I know rooster
when I see one
I know rooster and you are rooster also
for dinners for dinners that's a lot of
dinners come on you were and every time
you're gonna order the same thing you
stupid rooster wants to go on a coaster
you do bunny you think I just be able to
like tell them hey I know you I know you
like so intimately why don't you just
let me fix you by kissing you and maybe
more oh well there we go
how much said give me oh that's not
enough stupid okay I got a really wait
on the next one or else I'm never gonna
be able to get what I need it all right
there we go next level on that one no I
just need to take you for some boat
rides okay you need boat how much boat
ride cost 550 oh yes you much money here
we go again
it's a be out on the road again I think
this is like gonna take days I think
that's the idea here is that this is
gonna take days to get to the character
that we're trying to get to I just know
that's what it's gearing up for but I'll
get there I'll get there oh I'll get
there next level next level yeah got it
next level maybe I'm so good so dateable
bow ride oh look you're swimming with
the duck O's oh so cute oh look at you
you found a new purpose in life that's
so cute oh that's so cute
that's okay it's not that cute it's kind
of cute it's not that cute I'm debating
if I should perhaps I should not put
money into this I probably should since
my ears are still so soft but now I can
pet them with my own hands I'm really
fuzzy huh what happened oh boy one
second little lightheaded
being around you gets my heart racing
Eva vad är my lingering rabbit human DNA
don't talk about your DNA to be oh oh my
god one night is for your weekly karaoke
extravaganza
you're right in the middle of your
favorite Rhapsody when a fabulous
pegasus takes the stage with you
[ __ ] this is my jam Galileo even
though I'm sorry you and the Pegasus
proceeded to nail every note and bring
down the house it's only later that you
remember the pegasi aren't real it's one
of the cursed boys when you offer to
help the Pegasus laughs well if turning
me into a fabulous horse was your
convoluted plan and taking me out on a
date
mission accomplished you delicious
little marshmallow I was not too far off
careful don't sneak up all by me I'm
told I might kick unexpectedly it's too
risky
even I'm not gonna do it consumed 10k
how dare you get out of my house dinner
what not different about you and human
dinner
what the hell what happened to you what
do you think you are don't ever talk to
me again
all right Linton Roller I can at least
afford that there you go a lint roller
I'm gonna bury this that's actually a
good thing dummy read a wiki sometime
bacca bacca de su I'm out there I'm not
gonna lie I don't even know what the
nude is for way to begin you lose huh
you've reached the next stage with Kelby
oh you're out for a low-impact Trek
he'll be squawk laughs and one of your
dumb jokes oh man I can't believe how
often you make me laugh hey listen no
matter what happens next you and I good
just wanted you to know that I'm okay
with lean chicken it's fine super sad
note I don't want to get all weird on
you but I think I make a pretty handsome
[ __ ] why do you actually have voice
acting let's just go to dinner I don't
like the way you're looking at me I
don't like it don't hit me with those
eyes those eyes know I'm not having that
well so what's wrong with your neck
what's going on there what kind of gory
you got going on there you have a
thyroid problem look at that [ __ ] you're
next wider than your shoulders oh my god
wait there's something horribly wrong
with your neck I'm only just noticing
and now because we've been on this
dinner for so long also how are you
grabbing that martini
you can't grip with your
you can't top I'm uncomfortable I don't
want that date a horse 0.45 a I'm doing
good
y'all go on some coasters you don't do
that here let's go on coaster Wow
you should buckle up that is not safe
all right oh no I need for the next six
level 16 gamer coaster almost kill me
let's do it again
let's not I'm not sure I understand the
whole consumed 10k thing I can't give
you a gift so I don't know what you want
exactly wait I've been petting my fur
backwards on purpose it reminds me that
there are no good boys in this world
there are only dogs leading the blind
bad Volks no tree for you try to tell me
you were fapping or something have I
consumed enough how do I consume money
for you sir oh all right got you well
it's got to do what a wolves gotta do
yes yes yes the moon is super
interesting right now so shiny I want to
bite it okay well that doesn't know that
was a long way to go for a whole lot of
nothing what do you mean by 10k I don't
know what 10k means what do you want I'm
about to kiss this wolf it's the only
thing on my mind right now no that's not
weird I'm gonna I'm gonna kiss this wolf
mostly just cuz I want to get my stats
up so I can get a bigger boost I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna reset for a good
while I'm not gonna reset for a good
while so I got to make this good I got
to make the boost good not kissing the
wolf I can't make kissing the wolf good
that's weird and the interest of full
just closer to the answer is yes I can
currently lick myself and the temptation
is surprisingly difficult I wish you
would stop talking forever maybe I have
to consume ten thousand dollars in like
one go let's try this I only needed 10
veggies did that work God what do you
want for me consume 10 K consume 10 K
what what does consume 10 K I can I'll
eat whatever you want me to eat I guess
alright here's what I'm gonna do here is
what I'm going to do I am gonna let this
play in the background pretty sure if I
just let it run in the background yeah
it'll keep going it'll keep oh oh yeah
see that's pretty good
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna turn
the music all the way down can
uncensored what let this go in the
background
record something else and I will come
back to this when it is time to move
forward
only efficient with my time I'll see you
in just a bit
okay I'm back I've recorded a different
video but I've also made a lot of
progress my karaoke level is very high I
would I forgot to turn on gamer but I've
got a lot of money which means that I
can take NIM out on that weird dinner
which I can do you we're gonna go out on
a dinner a very expensive dinner and I
don't know why your ears are weird oh
it's gonna take a minute boo boo boo
what kind of dinner takes a minute what
kind of conversation needs to be had for
a minute boo you want a date with me and
I just like I'm sitting across the table
like boo hurry up I got a life to live
let's get on with it
we did it four thousand that's pretty
good that means hey hey Oh what big ears
you have all the better to hear you with
I'm getting hit on by a lot of furries
on the plus-side furries are surprising
and pleasant and charming floors I'm not
gonna make a judgment call about furries
here so I'm just gonna let that one
slide I'm not sure about the charming
flourish thing I don't know if anyone's
a charming flirter never never talk to
me ever again
Carnivale hey that looks familiar
everybody hold the phone here there's
something going on here I'm not too sure
about seems like a thing that I've seen
before
okay dates done you've now got oh my god
you've got so much left to go why do you
have so much left to go wait wait
consume 10 K what does that mean what I
but I did it okay I'm gonna need a few
gestures to prove you're good we'll
start by rubbing your tummy patting your
head and licking your elbow okay
sweetheart we can hang teehee I'm such a
plea word all right cool wanna know what
a gay Pegasus eats it's hey
Wow look at that I got all this stuff
let's learn you need herbs so I'm gonna
give you herbs and I'm sure those are
herbs herbs yeah you wanna go on a
coaster way too many times here we go
coaster yeah you're gonna die oh you can
fly no you're fine so I have to take you
on ten boat rides on ten boat rides ten
that boat would capsize you are a horse
horses weigh how much the horses weigh a
horse can weigh 840 to 220 pounds that's
a lot of pounds so let's just say you
weigh I'm gonna be generous you weigh a
thousand pounds that boat would capsize
I don't care if you can fly you ain't
flapping those wings in here you'd blow
those ducks right out of the water I
have a funny feeling it tricked me on
that first reset it tricked me it I
think it gets exponentially less bonus
so longer you go for your first one I
think it's I think it tricked me it
tricked me to do it I won't be tricked
again I should not be tricked why do you
need so many of these how much how much
oh my god oh you need less I'm gonna I'm
gonna go for you but this is a more more
important level up I guess nothing to it
but to do it like this is just one of
those situations where you just do it
nothing to it but to do it so I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna waste money on it now
when I can brute force my way through oh
I'm gonna beat this with efficiency hang
on I'm going to change something here
since I don't think right click does
anything in the game or we're gonna do
no that's not right all right there we
go
so you're saying we should try kissing
fine but this better not have been some
ruse or weird fetish I'm not above
biting faces well here goes nothing he's
the next stage with Volks so we got a
kiss for this to work lame all right
here goes suddenly there's a sheriff
sparkles and bubbles which reveal a
broody and still somewhat fuzzy guy Wow
look at that and I'm back to normal
ish at least my junk isn't fuzzy anymore
yes I can tell that right away
is honestly a lot further than I
[ __ ] need you to get no offense all
right well great now I just gotta get
you to the next level only I can make
the scroll wheel just be left click I
can't seem to rebind the scroll wheel so
I would just let this sucker fly more
time unlocked
yes all right I'm gonna I can't do it
with a macro so I might as well just do
with a mouse clicker so clicks per
second ten clicks per second let's try
25 just see how that goes
let's give her a try here ah that's good
okay good
hopefully doesn't have any sort of
software that's like you can't click
that high there's no way all right let's
crank this up a little more let's go for
50 clicks per second try that there we
go that's what I'm talking about that's
what I've been talking about my entire
life alright let's crank it up
let's go ridiculous 500 clicks per
second to death yeah we're buddies
alright oh we're buddies there we go 13
gamer I can't click those to victory all
right let's go as ridiculous as possible
let's go 5000 yeah I knew that was not
gonna work alright so 5000 is too much
what about 1000 now we're reaching some
kind of theoretical limit here all right
let's try 750 oh it works alright hey
what do you need you need six dinners
six dinners the promise my smartness is
not very high that's my problem a milli
a million a million ten thousands 10,000
seeds are you joking me 10,000 seeds
oh my god
that's so many this is feasible but my
god okay you know what now that I've got
this I'm just gonna come back in a bit
I'm gonna let this ride out again oh
you're about to level up let me just get
that real quick
I guess guess I'll keep cheating there
you go I see the two Assassin's I sent
to kill you have failed very well let's
make peace okay a handshake with poison
okay never mind I'm bored now let's go
beast movies you're a neat person and I
like your slash you're promoted to
bestie you know let's go get some
macaroons I'm dying for sugar today
alright so I'm gonna come back to this
but now I've got a path to the finish I
really don't want to give him money
because remember I'm outraged they used
my likeness without my consent get to
the bottom of this I'm not gonna give
him money either I'm not gonna do it I
won't do it okay I'm back in the saddle
for a sweet update um what did I get I
have no idea Ashley oh I'm a registered
nurse well that sounds pretty good
that's also seems like a lot of money
fifty per second wait that's actually
not that much better it's just takes a
long time to get that chunk of money
alright so we've gotten more healthy for
this for this reason right here yeah
we're gonna get there soon are we oh
yeah what about this well nevermind here
this this thing this is what we're gonna
do ten coasters you why do you want 10
of everything you suck kind of you suck
that's what you get oh my god how long
does it coaster take oh let's go to
coaster ten times yeah it's gonna
coaster ten times that sounds great a
laser I can't afford to give you a laser
oh my god okay ten iced creams I can do
ten ice creams that I can do let's just
go for ten ice creams how much is it but
okay I can still afford that that's fine
let's go on a freaking boat ride for 90
seconds you're pushing it you're pushing
it you are okay and that's done so now
we just got to get through this
yeah all right we're closing in on it
yeah Wow indeed I know very impressive I
have been known to be extremely
impressive oh okay yeah all right yeah
I'll still be friendly I just want to be
more than friends
gray ears make it hard knock Eve drop on
others I mean I'm hearing some grazy
gossip like real tell anova telenovela
stuff is that so I care so deeply about
that all right is there anyone else I
can get level 13 gamer and thousands
aids how much would that even cost a
million that would cost a million you
needy prick so what do I need let's get
to gamer let's just focus all on
money-making and gamer doing yeah there
we go nurse yeah all right so I'm gonna
I'm gonna let this lie sit back I'm
gonna get that money and I'm gonna get
that game or I'm gonna get you to the
next stop that's what we're gonna do all
right you feel me okay you feel me you
feel me all right we're gonna get there
all right be back we back in it we back
to win it we are a level 13 gamer we are
not gonna get to level 16 any time soon
so I'm gonna pass on that Oh any more
time blocks do I I'm making good buku
bucks but not as good as it could be all
right so what do I need to do for you
ten thousand still kosta I'm never gonna
be able to get that Ally maybe I could
do the dinners need six dinners I can do
this this one I can do I'm hoping I
could do that one but I don't think I
can do that one okay let's go on dinner
that many times
all right cool here we go okay got it
nailed it here we go
boink all right so that's done I just
need to get you four coffees just four
apparently I can't do through five
levels eleven confidence which is 20
seconds away so let me just wail on you
for a good bit I'm gonna wail on you
let's talk yeah let's talk yeah we're
good
whatever you said I like that you keep
saying words at me you say words so good
I've never heard a word Sayer as good as
you you words so good new good so word
word up am i right am i right I am right
that's gonna take a while
sunset to the worst lazy old Sun
moonlight abuzz for me yeah well maybe
you weren't too different from a puppy
after all I think I got a reset more I
think maybe it wasn't a trick I think I
just got a reset more because I don't
know if I got more diamonds for going
through the same thresholds as I got
before I'm not sure maybe I did maybe
that's how you get diamonds cuz
otherwise you can only get so many
diamonds right need more diamonds I'm
not gonna buy I'm I'm gonna reset after
I get this threshold I think there's no
way I could get that and that that's to
expand even the lasers too expensive I
can't afford a laser it's 680,000 I've
never gotten that I can't afford pies
will you think a coaster that's so much
money stop distracting me I gotta get
this done but there's gonna be a video
12 hours in the making but I'm gonna I'm
gonna forget to do it sha Boesky got it
poke you hard
alright got it sucks cuz I do sucks no I
can't
God I'm gonna take this 2.36 oh but 2.36
if I can get another one it would be a
lot right it would be very helpful how
much does a boat ride cost for oh
there's no way I'm not I'm gonna take
this we're going for it let's do it
doing it here we go gotta go again cuz
it's just like I don't I there's no way
and a certain point it would become
literally impossible again
deja vu curse bunny hey bub are you
doing let's good job let's get those
going pop that bad that's how we do all
right we're gonna talk there we go easy
peasy all right got it level to smart
you know I got this dinner we're going
for it go easy easy peasy
aha there you are got you skip that era
toodle Scootaloo it's not giving them
more diamonds I want more diamonds yeah
where's my diamonds you're good
okay all right you like boat right i
like boat ride we all go boat ride you
want a veggie I'll give you a veggie
there you go you want what do you want
hearts I give you horns and she boasts
key got it okay cool this is great and
skip okay gotcha hey wow look a [ __ ]
okay here we go you're gonna go on a
coaster huh yeah you are here we go
coaster oh look at that time flies when
you're having fun
I got the Unicorn yeah I got the Unicorn
okay got it got it got it okay how we
doing 31 hey that's pretty good you know
maybe we won't have to do too much in
Sandy maybe we could start over sooner
than I'm thinking we could I bet we can
alright I think the strategy is to reset
as many times as possible because that's
what that's the only thing that could
possibly get me closer to the end here
because otherwise it's just gonna take
forever and be physically impossible
because I'm right on money limited I'm
not quite heart limited because of my
perfectly sound strategy here but I am
money limited so I got to make sure I
get around that somehow you know what
I'm gonna what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
loop through this a few times at the
early level to see if it will help at
all and then if it doesn't and I screw
myself over which I don't think the game
would be designed to do that it's
probably a very linear or not
exponentially it's probably exponential
but probably fair so anyway I'm gonna
loop through a few times and I'll be
back once I get a higher number okay so
I went through it a couple times more
than a couple times I'm at eleven point
two two and I'm back up to roughly where
I was before these names are weird by
the way I've never mentioned that but
the names are weird but this person is
at this stage this stage this person
still needs a million this person is
somewhere along line uh but what am I do
now is I'm gonna leave this overnight
I've got eleven point two two which is a
good bit that's a good bit yeah that's
good so I'm gonna leave this overnight
I'm gonna let it go and I've got it set
for gamer caring and passionate which
are the next three things and I don't
know how far it's gonna go overnight but
hopefully it'll go pretty far cuz these
aren't taking all that long now that
I've got all this boost I got back to
this point in like 20 minutes so it's
going pretty good I found that there was
a
diminishing return the if there's a
minimum amount so basically I was able
to play through the first five minutes
over and over and over again to get
point three added on to my bonus each
time point three one actually but point
three so what I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna leave this overnight and I'm gonna
come back in the morning see you
tomorrow
I just woke up oh I had this leaning on
my macro button for clicks I have seven
point three nine million that's less
than I would have had but I put most of
my emphasis on stats gonna hear anything
oh yeah there we go area okay how'd the
hobbies do that's not bad that's not bad
at all
I need to switch this to that I need to
switch all these because they're gonna
take hours I don't have hours for that
[ __ ] actually you know what I'm gonna
take out this and this cuz that's not
gonna happen before I reset it I'm
definitely gonna reset before that okay
sorry I'm waking up I'm trying to
remember exactly what I was doing okay
um yeah reading that okay that all makes
sense I've got new jobs this one helped
me haha my 7a briefs to take seven
that's so many I like having the the
cheaper ones going but they're pretty
upgraded by now so I guess I got to
focus on the ones that are not upgraded
Oh screw you okay so have money and I'm
getting that upgrade so that I can get
the promotion for it because there's
achievements with promotions and I've
gotten I guess I haven't gone oh I did
get I got level eight no I got level
seven of that i unlock the teacher in
the barista I need one more achievement
to get another time slot which would be
really cool uh save up 1 million in cash
that's awesome
blush blush for one day why haven't I
gotten that yet I feel like you're sort
of good in this let's get these going
here alright now what am I not gonna
need oh [ __ ] I've unlocked two new
characters hot tits
ok I'm one away no I'm two away god damn
it I'm two away from where I need to be
any 29 passionate there's no way there's
no way I can't oh my god ok whatever
it's it's fine ok so the first thing I'm
going to do
I'm gonna get you a laser I'm gonna take
you on a coaster ten times but to do
that I need there's no way that's gonna
happen it's it's just good that I
unlocked it you know what I mean I'm
gonna get the this the quicker cheaper
one's going I'm gonna get you a laser
cuz I can afford that boom
what I'm sorry do you think that just
because you're a horse you get to
disrespect me like that I gave you a
laser I'll shoot it in your eye you
stupid crap that's you that's what you
look like you stupid I just realized
that we've mainly acquainted who you
look with tell me something about
yourself are you indeed yaoi no I was
met a humor you see breaking the fourth
wall is a fun ride and divisive works
eviction right okay hey I got more uh
more time oh dude
now it's like that that's totally
readable and definitely better why
wouldn't they have just made the bar
smaller and stacked them on top of each
other so I can see them properly and not
have to guess alright whatever it's fine
45 hammock so I dunno why does anything
need 45 mimics that's so ridiculous okay
whatever I might be able to get that I
don't know if I have enough money for 45
hammocks cuz hammocks cost 150 so 10 of
them would be one point five four of
that would be six I'm close I
I think I could make that but let's see
I still need to spend a Milian you cuz
this arguably this level is better so
let's spend a milli oh that gave two
hundred thousand I didn't need to have
the click spammer on you well whatever
you already clicked up so good Oh
Carnaval yeah about Carnivale oh god
yeah yeah indeed a bull [ __ ] then I
haven't done vote for warmups
I haven't eaten breakfast I haven't done
nothing I literally rolled out of bed
and came over here which is cool cuz I
haven't done that since my World of
Warcraft days I used to like roll out of
bed and just log on and do my dailies or
whatever it was and rather Lich King
because I wanted the fishing stuff and a
few other reputation yes
so we got a truck usin to change back
righto I was worried it would take
trans-fats or something let's do it oh
you just got feathers behind your that's
fine mostly be feathered guy appears
well that's a little weird
that's a little coincidental that your
your team jersey has a giant [ __ ] on it
alright so you need two pies a lot of
love wow wow wow we you i got guts for
you i don't even know why i got guts for
you okay so let's do saw i don't think
i'm gonna get the money maybe maybe i
don't know i might get the money it just
depends on if i dedicate more to the
jobs cuz i've got a lot of jobs right
now so I just have to dedicate the time
to it but I haven't dedicated the time
to it whatever it's not important it
really is not that important the
important thing is that we're getting
better for the bonus but I want a big
beefy bonus before I will have to reset
again even though I've done this
overnight I'm I am an after reset again
but I want a big beefy bonus and I want
to make as much as possible
pies are 205 coaster costs 640 yeah and
then we need a lot of this stuff and
let's unlock the new characters let's do
that first let's unlock them because I
think that's more important to see
what's gonna happen okay anon are ain't
on you decide to try searching the
Internet's for information on the
manimals you cursed manimals you grab
you grab see it at an internet cafe and
start internetting but after a few quick
searches you realize you've accidentally
hacked into NORAD oh oops a mysterious
message pops up on your screen from a
hacker called a non you congratulate you
on your leet hacking skills that should
to be spelled l33t hacking skills and
calls for a truth yo stranger and your
hacking skills they're dope tickle me
impressed
truth I can you believe you beaten the
best time even as I was trying to stop
you
that kind of hacking demands a point to
celebrate this is not this is not right
Scottish let's go I'm not the computer
just in Freudian don't mind me
affliction you look up and are surprised
to see a lemur we're here expecting to
see something more human a little boys
you cursed
this affliction is your fault Oh at
least you didn't turn me into a frog
long lonely story the other one names
unknown the Bible with by the by ways so
talking gave a hundred and seventy
that's so many that's so many why is it
so many that's so many let's go on
fifteen dinners Wow on your phone huh
okay 15 dinners
God is there any greater Richie is there
any greater achievement mankind and
unlimited free bread there's nay I
checked it's not like I can do a
Scottish accent anyway but now that I'm
tired like I just woke up I'm definitely
not gonna be able to do it oh it's just
sunglasses goes oh my god four million I
don't think so alright boat ride let's
do the boat ride cuz we can do that oh
my god well if you weren't blocking my
view maybe I could see something nice
1.75 that's good but I want a lot more
I'm already at like 11 and it's additive
not multiplicative and I'm getting more
diamonds ooh also I wanted to mention
the thing I'm gonna get with my diamonds
is I'm gonna get this temporary 48 hour
boost it's only 20 it's like it's such a
racket like 10 gets you double 15 get to
420 gets you 8 though like that's that's
nuts
and apparently you can get multiple of
those so if I can get 40 diamonds which
I have no idea it's just like depends on
how high I can get these guys up but if
I can get 40 diamonds that's nuts
okay good first I don't have many people
how and money to be one I mean if you
don't make a big deal out of it just go
don't go running off to update your
Facebook's at whatever it's annoying you
own a diamond that's good I need one
more
alright sunglasses I'm not gonna give
you those but you might be able to take
on this coaster boy heart that's not
good yeah that's not good that you're
clutching your heart like that I think
you might actually die ah I I really
don't want to disappoint you but maybe I
haven't been clear I'm allergic to
rollercoasters we should definitely
consider not really doing that again
well you know I don't care what you
think
cuz you're stupid
I'm smart now this is a harrowing
journey this is a harrowing adventure
because I don't just have to unlock the
character that I am apparently I have to
get that character the point where they
turn human to even show that it's
somewhat me so I'm not sure if you're
looking for a boyfriend but it just so
happens that I've been looking to be a
boyfriend do you want a boyfriend yes I
mean what a great coincidence I'm really
glad that worked out for everyone yes
starting to get used to the stairs and
Sun looks I'm pretending I'm some sort
of rabbit based celebrity at least you
get an achievement for all of these let
me unlock the next new character
calculate how much do calculators cost
not that much I mean a lot but not as
much as I thought it was gonna be and I
might be able to afford that which would
get me to the next big threshold ooh
that's new okay one day while you're out
looking for more guys you see a cat
stuck in a tree thinking it might be one
of them you scramble up to save it not
noticing a giant blue bull waiting at
the base of the tree my friend the boy
else was surprising clarity you have
saved this kid when I could not you are
truly brave and wonderful Garrett is
happy to meet you you must forgive the
air it he was not always so how do you
say full of bull but he is now and he
must accept his kit and rescuing days
are over thank you again for your heroic
deed so obviously the cat isn't a guy
but the bull is he quickly climbed down
and explained the situation huh we must
become friends to break this magical
curse
daddy scares favorite thing to do let us
begin this friendship now ah did you
dare it is always pleased to see you
does not even need a half a moment to
consider alright great I don't have 21
confidence I don't have 16 smart but I
do have 20 diamonds which means that I
can buy an 8 x boost which is a lot and
that might get me there faster I think
this is the best use of my diamonds
better than jumping ahead in progress
because for 48 hours which is the time
period I have to really get this gun and
I'm willing to commit to it I have to
make this happen I basically have just
today to make this happen so I have to
do the boost and it seems the most
effective right there's this there's
this bundle for 230 that would do eight
seven a skip and fifteen time blocks but
I don't have 230 and I don't think I'd
ever get to 30 there's no way you'd get
that naturally in the game consumable
boosts boy yeah there we go okay so now
I have an eight oh eight times that
boost eight times eleven really oh my
goodness gravy eight times eleven are
you is that Oh a thousand per Oh okay
what do I need I need passionate and I
need confidence okay I'm getting
confidence I'm working on passionate oh
[ __ ] that's way more than I thought it'd
be that's way I knew it's gonna be a
good idea I knew it I knew it was a good
idea okay I need 16 smart I have Alfie
I've caring that needs smart as well you
need calculators I need money
so who needs healthy did someone need
healthy okay you have healthy so let's
take off healthy for now because I want
to make more months
let's get you calculators wait let's
make sure this is the most effective use
of my months you need confidence that's
gonna happen now that before that was
not gonna happen now it might happen
okay you're gonna get as soon as smart
rolls up which shouldn't be long another
minute you're the cheapest one right now
for these calculators Wow holy crap oh
my god look at the talk button oh that's
so much better look at that holy [ __ ]
okay gift calculator go for it how much
does a carnival cost two point seven
yeah we can do that we can make that
happen but let's let money build up
first you're basically done now so I
just need to take you on the Carnival
and then this is a big threshold big
threshold alright here we go big
threshold coming up oh man that speed
that boost was so worth it
okay so I I would like to kiss you I
kiss you like for real this time and uh
if we want to do more than kiss
this is just for the curse for magic Oh
No
I'm not usually much for selfies but
it's a new picture to make sure you
don't forget about me see you good suit
everybody avert your eyes oh that's not
so bad but I don't want to unlock
uncensored mode
I just don't ok I don't want to do that
it's fine and you're fully human and you
look like you'd use a nuzzle and I am an
accomplished Nosler never say that
masquerade what the hell that's good oh
my God look how expensive that is why
what happened to you you greedy bastard
if you'd be insisting on pestering me
you can stick around but be warned that
I'm still playing in my revisions that
I'm still playing in my revenge and
it'll be a sight to behold when I knock
it good we're on the booth on the same
page grab a controller let's give all
right cool I got another diamond
perching on the toilet is my lease new
least favorite thing okay
boat ride I can get that cuz these are
still dirt cheap for some reason woosh
woosh woosh woosh why are the fish
coming up to take a pic of you the koi
fish now fifty nine thousand followers
and a lot of creepy fan art in the 4chan
the internet didn't let me down today
the Internet let me down right now there
is always pleased to see you alright
whatever let's go to dinner
Wow again the neck it's just a lot of
neck problems going on with these man
Des Moines and why are none of these
manimals drinking danimals what's what I
don't understand oh well sorry man that
went up quick okay confidence and it's
gonna be a bit for that
sunglasses I just don't have the money
for it coasters cost a lot sunglasses
cost a lot yeah I might have capped out
on those but the good news is times
eight on these things is way more like
that's this boost is now 2.5 times 8
which is 20 20 more times speed which is
more than I had even last night in one
go but let's see if I can push this a
little more because I just need to get
confidence and I need to get smart did
you you're fine on this
yeah yeah you're you're good I just need
a little more smart which I'm gonna get
in a minute and 20 and then I've got you
on that stage I don't know if I'm gonna
get more diamonds cuz like it's really
hard to get diamonds naturally you have
to get you get one per these levels so
theoretically there's one two left there
three four five six in the a 29 30 31 32
33 34 35 36 and then those guys so I
could get a couple more boosts which
would be really cool I could get I could
get some more boosts a but I need to I
need to have more more diamonds which
means I got to reset more times which
means I got a lot of things Oh
confidence gonna take a while for you
right now shoving the corn in your gob I
love that haunted house more and more
with each ride I just want to kiss every
little ghost from gobble and I see sure
you do
oh you're ready okay I'm looking for a
character reference photo my resume I'm
putting your number on there and they're
going to see and that sings for me I
glued Claire I'm glad we understand one
another also I'm not from Scotland if
you couldn't tell by my accent this
wasn't the most awkward way ever to ask
for your number
don't be slandering me with your
baseless accusations while we're outside
getting some much-needed Sun and on
looks up for him son laughing look at
this little guy he fell down oh by the
way we're friends now don't make a big
deal of it the next what that tell yells
them boom a foo in my face is getting
rekt I don't know what that means
hey piano I'm not gonna waste time on
piano just because I don't have time to
waste on piano it's just like with the
promotions they get they get way better
but the the promotion like bonus on the
barista I just got to level it up and
then I gotta get smart to get that one
anybody else waiting you're waiting on
Amex and that you're never gonna happen
in a million years neck pillows cost
eight that they're never gonna happen
not this round anyway you just need
confidence and that's gonna take a while
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna go like get
ready for the day cuz I haven't been so
I'm gonna go get ready for the day and
then I will be back at some point
okay I'm back I did absolutely nothing
to get ready for the day so what can you
do but I'm back
and we've made progress we have streamer
or glitch hunter I don't know what that
means but I guess I'm hunting glitches
2.2 4000 per second that's not that good
and it's really slow and we're not gonna
be able to upgrade it fast it's nice
that we unlocked it but I'm gonna stick
with the other ones we've got twelve
point three million have the confidence
but we'll get confidence in ten minutes
we do have something else we need what
do we need disciplined but it takes so
long to get disciplined ah I needed
something something else I thought I
needed something I either way I can now
buy the hammock
that's what I can do I can buy the
hammocks so let me buy the hammocks
alright you suck you know next time I'll
get you
45 hammocks boom okay oh you think a
kiss might break the curse well let's do
it just allow me one last chance to
admire my hey it's so pretty much more
comfortable than the ones I'm used to
before you can offer you kiss - kiss Eli
delt break the spell he grabs him makes
out with you a bit it works he changes
mostly back oh wow would you look at
that I've just felt like we were at the
makeup stage but this is a lucky
accident
yay Eli oh hey I'm partially transformed
back need meat good for you awkward
bestie a thousand and one pizzas alright
let's see if we can do it I don't know
or a thousand and one pizzas you just
ate a thousand pizza
I like this this is a good trend you're
starting here alright cool great I could
probably do it okay here let's just do
this ten dinners wow really
okay no I just need the hearts and Bam
Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam ah okay I'm gonna gently
place you in the crusher Soho has mostly
a technicality I'm sure you'll be
bangable by the end of the week sounds
good
great let's go shopping okay here we
finally elusively la prowling the wilds
let's make walking pounce on
unsuspecting prey okay I just need the
confidence six minutes away from getting
this this level of confidence ooh but
that'd be so much more bonus oh we're
doing good did I get enough smart I
think I got the smart I needed I don't
remember why I needed smart why do they
need smart I think it was for someone
else I don't think I need smart anymore
which means that I can focus more on
just the money aspect which i think is
what I need dare it mistake your tickle
for jabbing him and eyeball silly
mistake I like it yeah it's cool I think
Garrett's all right the rest of these
manimals not so good but Garrett you're
alright alright I just need to wait for
the competence so I'll do that and then
I'll be back alright so I'm I'm less
than two minutes away from getting the
confidence level up but I wanted to do
pause for a moment and just talk about
like my mental state in regards to this
this is probably the most effort I've
ever put into a gaming related video
maybe not considering like the 20/20
modes of five nights at Freddy's and
what not because I put a lot of effort
into that but I'm putting a lot of time
into this like I got up and immediately
went here I started recording this I set
this up overnight like this is the
longest time span I've put into
something and I'm not even there yet and
I just want to talk about why because
I'm not entirely sure why yes there's a
mystery afoot I want to know why I'm in
this I want to hear the dialogue lines
straight from the horse's mouth or the
cat's mouth and I want to know what's
the dealio with this what they've got in
here because there's there's a mystery
afoot and I want to know what the
mystery is
Oh more time unlock that's good cool but
at the same time why am I so invested in
this I'm very curious like I can't come
up with an immediate answer other than
just like I do like idol games in a
weird way I like finding the mo
efficient route to things it's like a
very nice clear goal that I can easily
work towards in incremental steps and I
think as a human just like we naturally
are inclined to do things like that and
we're naturally drawn towards like those
kinds of things so it's it's kind of fun
and it's kind of weird and it's a little
bit of a challenge for me to try to see
if I can actually accomplish so to do
this so you are saying that somehow
through the power of friendship you can
break the curse
Garrett knew it he knew that friendship
was magic and let the friendship be yeah
[Music]
hello my friend Garrett just came from
China shop owner was surprisingly
accommodating healthy and peaceful I'm
not gonna get those there's no way yeah
there's no way that would take another
28 minutes and I think I'm good on that
okay so that's no good discipline that's
not happening maybe it's happening would
that be happening I don't think so
getting to 19 would take a lot 75
hammocks I don't think I might hit with
that right Oh 314 pies good golly I
might be able to do this with the
sunglasses because I know that it sounds
like it costs a lot but it's actually
not that much compared to how much money
I'm making okay it's going this coaster
whoosh alright and then you just need
hearts alright do you want to be it do
you want to be a thing with me I guess
okay fine whatever
it's not like I'm gonna say no at this
point I slash the dogcatchers tires
today I'm not gonna lie I feel pretty
damn great good for you okay
Oh discipline maybe I could do that how
much the tools cost Oh nope I can't do
that eighty-four million
Oh take way too long okay but you I
might be able to take care of cuz I can
get sunglasses again and the dinners
aren't that much alright nice dinner hey
nice dinner hey I would do nice dinner
hey okay this is good there's gone well
this is going surprisingly well and
almost there almost there almost there
almost there ah my sir
kaboom BAM no matter how tough gets it's
easy to keep your with you my corner the
only problem is they're like if you
think I say is like 90% cheesier is that
a chicken thing I'm going to pretend
locker to use diamonds man I'm having
trouble finding pants it's just not a
chicken's world out here Oh mmm it's
like I'm maybe on that one I don't know
if I'm be able to get that and I don't
know if I'd be willing to for a bonus of
four that's incredible and then I could
loop through a whole bunch Oh and then I
could get more on the loop throughs oh I
could do it I could do it I could do it
good I can do that that might be better
than waiting for this next little
increment when I could get that
increment really quickly with the loop
throughs and now that I've got that
eight times boost plus the four like
yeah that's pretty good
how long would I have to wait for that I
mean I'm gonna wait for the discipline
along with the discipline take oh never
mind
discipline take too long I've reached
some kind of a peak here I think and I
don't think the disciplines happening
either okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna reset I'm gonna get this four and
then I'm gonna do what I did before
which is reset from the beginning a lot
because I'll be able to get a bigger
reset quicker and with this times eight
it'll be so fast so let me just show you
what I do for one and then you know I'll
be back all right we're gonna go for
this so when you reset I think I've
shown this but now it's it's gonna be
insane with this cuz not you you start
obviously the same place seamstress you
wow that's pretty much the same you get
this you go here you take a dinner you
go here done and then you get this and
then you're there and then your friend
level and it's literally this and as you
go up it's small right here but there's
a certain threshold that you can get to
that will help you along the way
boat ride bankers don't like us going
kiss oh this is so much better
there's so much better give you a seat
now I'm limited by just how much I can
click which I like that's good
G you like that G I like that G let's go
on coaster
I got another job hell yeah give me that
yet and look at this I've already got
0.19 that's less than it was oh no no it
wasn't no it wasn't cuz I got
stun and then I went on the coast for a
few times okay that's what I did what I
did is yeah point three one that's what
I got to every single time before but
that took me a minute like a mint two
minutes maybe that took me snow so fast
so fast all right so I'm gonna loop
through this a bunch and get a lot more
bonus my objective is good too like I'm
hoping I can get to like 25 maybe even
30 bonus which would make that endgame
go that much faster so I'll be back once
I got that taken care of but there's
good there's good I'm excited about this
why am I excited about this okay update
I have made up I've made a lot of
progress I am back up to roughly where I
was but I've got thirty six point three
six boost with two point seven seven in
the bank I have made tons of progress in
terms of achievements in terms of
hobbies I've got almost everything above
20 which is gonna give me a oh there's
another achievement right there which is
good uh and I've made progress in terms
of money I have a lot of money which
means that I can do a lot of things now
I'm gonna do the tools boom carnival
seven thanks for real yeah you you will
come carnival easy done things are so
fast now by the way things are stupid
fast and hopefully this will get me
enough diamonds in this next section to
get the multiplication again for even
more fastness because even if I only had
enough diamonds for like the two times
are the four times I would still be an
incredible boost I can't sleep I can't
eat you're ruining me just say you'll be
here tomorrow we'll call it even
I'm gonna kiss you now oh god no oh no
oh it's fine it's about the same hey I
took this picture for you I lost my
shirt and didn't feel like finding
another one I guess you're welcome
hit me up for dates or not whatever so
we're making progress
watch I'm not gonna give you a watch how
much is a bull ride cost okay I can do
this
I could also do which is a tree cost 372
million per tree I'll take you to dinner
that's nice and cheap BLUP that's nice
okay bull ride
we're just making progress we haven't
been able to make before right there we
go that's what I call no matter if the
curse is not broken Garrett enjoys your
person very much we are French former
right good guts creative you're asking
so much of me Oh
guts in Korea I don't even know if I
want to be able to get that but I need
diamonds that's what I need I've done so
many loops I the only real way that I
can make significant changes by having
diamonds I just gotta have those
diamonds if I don't I'm kind of screwed
I'm not gonna reset for at least a good
bit I guess honestly the masquerade is
probably gonna be the cheapest Wow
masquerade huh oh you're a God as a
bunny that's that's fair I guess I'll do
the tools for you and then bull rides
don't take your shirt off
don't don't do that now you haven't
reached that level yet my hands are
super sweaty from the anticipation of
all that all right okay so I think we're
reaching another dead end but I really
wanna I really wanna uh 26 oh so much
I'm gonna have to reset our night oh but
I don't want to but oh oh wait I can't
buy it oh so if I can just get three
more diamonds I can get the four times
boost which would be a big boost I'd be
a big beefy boost I'd be either way I
gotta let it wait I can let it sit it's
got a ruminate it's got just like
Fester's it's gonna fester I'm gonna
leave it to fester it'll be good okay
status update it is time to update again
cuz we can get three more diamonds by
doing this blink that's a diamond every
time I think I couldn't possibly love
you even more you do something the rocks
my socks and my world there's a lot of
rock and going on in other worlds words
any time you may wonder about it I'll
tell you the same I love you with all my
heart
o3 dot what I didn't know that keep
three diamonds hey things are less awful
when you're around so stop leaving a
warning
you as an abusive relationship I don't
feel comfortable folks if that is your
real name which it's not cuz it's weird
anyway but also I got this tree right
here incus I mean I don't need I thought
I was gonna get three on each of these
maneuvers but I got more maneuvers so
I'm gonna do that
what's that we got a snog to break the
curse cliff slippin slippin hey really
are you sure a plaint won't do the trick
oh well
kiss kiss it kiss it is here goes
nothing mmm well purchase purchase all
right well there you go fifty thousand
coffee
I miss pants never thought I would say
that me neither
pastor ba keep asking Garrett if he has
a case of blue bulls but then they laugh
at him is he missing the joke coaster
wow you you don't fit Garrett is sorry
if his friendship is not strong enough
to break the curse if you wish to give
up he understand do you want to keep
going oh you have renewed Garrett sense
of purpose and confidence
you're very good news glad you were here
someone tried to Brandy's bottom if they
come back it's just with the shooing
away man Garrett you got a lot of
requirements so with that though though
with that that is good what we can do is
we can do these pies oh can I do this
boys I could I could do these pies yeah
I I know you love pie I know you do who
doesn't oh okay there we go and then
boat rides wait what's going on with
your foot why is your foot shooting out
a rainbow well that doesn't make any
sense
why is that happening I dare say I've
taken a shine to you love and by that I
mean imagining you own the full bearskin
rug in front of my fireplace it has to
be full of some of my best friends of
bears hey find a penny pick it up and
all day long you're now aware of the
feeling of your tongue in your mouth and
you're breathing intentionally hey he
okay 700 billion at least I can get that
achievement that needs hearts a billion
hearts okay I think that's all I'm gonna
get for now how much does five million
times how many did you need I guess
that's only 50 million I could do that
wait I could do this
the more I get done the more I the more
I get bonus yeah yeah yeah I could do
this this isn't cheating by the way this
is a totally legitimate strategy given
that they cheated me by putting me in
this game maybe it might not be me I
have to determine for myself that's why
we're getting to the truth of it do you
need so much coffee why do you need so
much coffee this is too much coffee this
is more coffee than someone who drink in
a lifetime I was thinking today that I'd
like to come start there awkwardly
flirting with you
I recommend things go further than that
do you make peace with that good there's
nothing worse about the awkward flirting
then it's actually being awkward I can't
abide that much cringe in my life ah you
don't need their gesture settings I
really looked this good okay how much
the calculator too much I can't afford
that okay so now I have reached the
theoretical limit but he gives hearts
faster than the other person so I'm
gonna use you to get to the achievement
you're gonna achieve an eyes me I need
300 million more there we go got it okay
I didn't get any more time slots but
that's okay I just wanted that
achievement okay we're doing good we're
doing real good before I go I'm just
gonna do some else there's another
achievement for
a million gifts so many how would
someone do that I can't even get up to a
million guess how I'm gonna be able to
get a million gifts that's impossible
that's literally impossible okay anyway
so what am I do now is I have 19 diam
owns my resets gonna add five which is
not that good considering I can reset
and get one every like five minutes but
they're still pretty good so I've got 19
diamonds I can get this times for max
boost of 64 well I mean how would I even
get that wait are you saying that when I
click this it's gonna multiply that by 4
it's not gonna go up to 12 it's gonna go
up to 32 oh my god oh my god oh oh my
god 30 but but well hey wait a minute
well huh but it doesn't seem to have as
profound effect as I thought it would be
that's that's so much more that is so
much more that is there's so much more
why is it not why is everything not just
suddenly exploding with progress why am
I not making unbelievable amounts of
money which I should be right do I still
need a reset Garret achievement 3 yeah
that's a good one all right cool cool I
guess maybe I could keep going then
confidence outgoing I mean that's
incredible but it doesn't seem to be
incredible with what's happening yes
astonishing but it's not very
astonishing with what I'm seeing my
money isn't going up nearly as intensely
as I assumed it would seem shorter I
guess I'm confess old okay I'm gonna use
this and I'm still gonna go ahead and
I'm gonna reset again and again I'm
gonna go through another cycle of
resetting to get even higher boost
because I'm still two characters away so
I gotta be a long bit actually away so I
just gotta I gotta slog through I gotta
go I gotta get those bonuses so that's
why I'm gonna do so I'll be back in a
bit I guess
is a quick update the faster you go the
better bonus you can get I've just been
going for like five minutes and I'm good
gonna add a 2.1 cuz I'm finally slowing
down here but only just now okay update
update big update big update okay so I
got two oh there we go Garrett and one
day I'm on well when you bring up the
subject of kissing Garrett gets really
big Rin wait a minute
this may be a trick to give Garrett
smooches you are tricky well let us try
anyway a few sparkles bubbles later and
there's a lot lot less bullying your
life
alright huh Garrett how you doing good
to see you Garrett out appreciate four
four stomachs you could eat all the
wheat grass on ironically ah still got
so far to go haha
still got so far to go but I need
thirty-three confidence I am at I'm one
away from thirty-three confidence if I
can just see him me I can see me that
I'll know that I'm close I'm so far away
aren't I I'm so far away I'm gonna have
to do another round of like grinding
again I'm gonna have to do it I'm gonna
have to do another round of it I know I
am that's okay because I can do it I can
do it anyway I got a lot of money so
let's spend the money too but before we
sink into a deep pit of despair I can
buy this drone now so you're gonna get a
drone kaboom
guns oh observant I'm already working on
that you need smart okay smart so I ride
my box class not thinking about you in a
crashed news reposts it's no real story
to this story I just like telling you
the cool and I love you just FYI I'm
afraid at this point you're just plain
old stuck with me got a real hair I'm
going on here thought I look cute might
lead later just kidding I took like 500
of these until I finally had one that
didn't look weird let me know if you
have it down for a little one-on-one
shirts versus skins I'll let you pick
whichever one I wear
okay gross weird cool much does a ticket
cost seven billion Oh
seven billion I don't think there's any
point to getting this but I'm gonna do
it anyway just for the sake of the
rewind bonus got that you did it I did
it and that means I get six point three
this 69 drones you suck so much it's so
far away so far away so far and yet so
far I think I just got a loop through
I'm gonna do it here we go alright I'll
be back okay I've got an announcement
there is Wow
Ichiban the name is Ichiban yes your
search for more manimals leads you to
the local convention where adorable fans
of all fandoms have gathered to dress up
and show their love you discover that
your favorite streamer Ichiban is making
an appearance so you rush over to meet
him that is a tiger that is a pink tiger
are you me Ichiban me you're big time I
used to work at a sushi place called
Ichiban it's practically practically me
also the achievement when I got this was
a Maya cat and like that video I made
only to discover that he's grown a huge
fuzzy beard which is odd for his brand
you line up for an autograph and are
already swooning over his gorgeous voice
before you realize he hasn't grown a
beard at all he's been turned into a
minimal you quickly explained the
situations and he replies am i a cat no
just kidding I totally noticed then my
subscribers have exploded but I suppose
I should change back before someone gets
me neutered which is the responsible
thing to
let's go right uh who are you again so
you're the one behind all this I should
have known actually I shouldn't have
known I've just always wanted to say
that well look at you you've got the
neck goyda thing that everyone else says
going on pro-gamer straight I've already
got that got to be a level level 34
gamer huh I'm not gonna get that anytime
soon but I've got you I have you you are
there and I have you you're me aren't
you you're me we're going on a dinner
date you and I we're not done yet cuz I
can't confirm this until you turn out of
a mandible into a man man listen I know
that that's not what a napkin is for but
sometimes you just got to disembowel
something with your back feet and you
use what you have available whoa wait a
sec I got turned into a tiger but
another guy got turned into a chicken
but that's certainly an odds silver
lining at least there's no rainbows
coming out of my butter bread on my face
or whatever come to think of it the
Internet is a bit of an odd place for
cats I haven't been this angry since I
was toast no I'm not gonna explain that
reference not this angry since you're a
toast it's like the game
I am thread the game in which I got
angry and you're me aren't you ha ha ha
I'm building the lawsuit as we speak
this was all evidence my lawyers will be
in touch wolf but I can't make a case
yet I can't make a case yet I have to go
around the block just a little more
because I can't afford anything else
I've not mastered three men I can do
this but I gotta go around the block a
lot more hey 7.24 though that's a big
bonus tad but I'm gonna try to double
this or more I don't know what I'm gonna
try to do I'm just gonna do it again
so we go everybody
I passed we get mine BAM fast you
okay good biosea okay so I'm a genius
right Amy Finn genius I recorded my
Mouse's movements for this repetition
I'm not doing this because I recorded
this it took a long time and it was very
finicky but this is the recorded
movements of my mouse that I for the
past two hours have been trying to get
right and it looks like it's working and
in double speed and it should repeat
even if I'm not here which should give
me all the repeat multiplier I could
possibly want it's working
it works oh there's no audio to it but
imagine there's game sounds cool all
right cool bye all right so it's dawn on
the third day it turns out there is a
cap on how much reset bonus you can get
but that doesn't matter because 256 is
still a lot and I think that means I can
get to where I need to get that is four
times as much as I had before I'm
starting from the beginning again uh but
I'm gonna go up to where I was before
and I'm gonna see let's see where it
gets me I'm just gonna see where it gets
me oh yeah I just are the third down but
we'll get this I'm gonna get this I'm
gonna get this okay all right I'll see
it a bit I've hit a wall and I don't
like that I've hit a wall
because I am at max reset bonus with the
max amount of bonus I could possibly
afford with the diamonds they gave me
and I'm still really far away and I know
that I haven't been waiting long enough
to wait for the money to build up but
it's not the money that's the limiting
factor I'm at thirty two of this it's
still gonna take ten minutes for this
level I got to get to 33 and then after
that it's like exponential north you're
gonna take thirty minutes than an hour
then I'm just like four hours it's just
gonna keep going and there's no other
ceiling of progress that I can get
besides buying a diamond does uh so I'm
in a bit of a hard place I don't know
how this is gonna
go because I've been at this for three
days right I've been at this for three
days but it's not just a matter of being
at it for three days I have done the
physical limitation of what I can do as
far as the reset boost I don't know why
the reset boost is capped because that
doesn't usually happen in games like
this but I feel like it's artificially
capped to make it standard level of
progress for the amount of characters
that they are and they will probably
raise the cap for more characters coming
out as they come out because that would
make sense because it creates a very
standard time curve for how much it is
but it's [ __ ] because I've been at
this for so long I do not want to put
money into it and yeah just like it's I
get it idle games are a time sink that's
by design
but this is a time sink with an
artificial cap on it it's putting a
ceiling on something and I don't like it
I don't know what I'm gonna do at this
point I just wanted to point that out I
need to get to this dude Ichiban and I
need to make him at least not Dan
Manimal danimals Dan I'm tired
oh my god they're taunting me not to
sound ungrateful for your help my
precious my little bird my precious
little bird but I don't suppose we could
hurry this process up a little yes
perhaps with a generous purchase of
diamonds oh you suck oh you suck no I
will not buy your diamonds okay I'm
gonna get the pit mechanic maybe that'll
change everything maybe
[Music]
now who are you again
I don't know I don't know what I'm gonna
do
okay so I've let it run in the
background and I'm about to go do a
stream but it's it's it's making a lot
of progress it is making more progress
than I thought it would make I just
realized that I needed to wait quite a
bit more time I'm getting a random
smattering of what I think I might need
I'm definitely gonna need gamer let me
just emphasize that because if this is
me then gamer would probably be
coincidentally needed but I can do the
next level on this so I'm gonna go ahead
and do that uh never mind I'm not gonna
do that let's pause the jobs for a
little bit and then alright so game on I
warn you though I'm likely gonna record
and upload most of this to YouTube
that's just how I roll
that's not how I roll alright good okay
you break the curse
I get the views we do what we do best
and we'll lick this thing like I lick my
balls here's what I've discovered so far
scratching posts are lit I never say lit
so this month that's one in the column
of not me
I don't say lit unless I'm being ironic
or stupid I didn't think smart would be
there I don't know what that says about
me but I didn't think smart would be
there now I can't do another one I can
do another you I mean it could be just
that you're good with animals or perhaps
Bauer's in particular it is probably
best we do not over-clean please alright
I find myself oddly jealous of other
piggies his tails are curly and it
I've tail Envy how my heart yarns
frickin weirdo okay shampoo fifty of
those I can do that easily that's
nothing
this ain't nothing grumble ah oh it's
it's
I've written apartment for you and here
are days roses are red violets are
allowed in the cockpit of friendship you
are my pilot so get in my [ __ ] and yeah
okay I made my friends are with a spider
she tells me I'm truly some Pig ass
affect our friendship will last a long
time and not ending now quenching tada
they're healthy goddamnit everything
needs everything oh you suck
let's try to get smooches all right
you're gonna turn to a man I've already
seen you as a man then we're making so
much progress diamond healthy and
disciplined well 69 drones I can do the
two tickets that's what I can do so I
can do the two tickets even though they
cost billions of dollars we okay good
all right hey Mar mellow so my paints
random will came on book well then I
fell on the couch here took this photo
as evidence may I keep you warm on cold
lonely nights hugs and kisses
all right cool good great what does the
vacuum cost six yeah that's Wow hey to
you too
hey how you doing am I even bothering
with this it doesn't matter anymore it's
not like I'm gonna get any diamonds out
of this I've already gotten your
diamonds I've heard none that that that
you're next but I can't afford I can't
afford a vacuum God and there's nothing
left to buy except at I'm skip how would
I can't afford that I'm not gonna be
able to get enough for that Oh God
I guess I just gotta let it go all right
I'm gonna do my stream I guess we need
healthy and discipline and smart okay
move this disciplined smart and then I'm
willing to bat gamer is gonna come into
play here I don't know for sure but that
is my bet I've got healthy outgoing
smart game or competence disciplined
creative I think that's gonna be enough
to get me to the next section
hopefully mustard drones cost much as
how many drones do you need 69 drones I
can afford that technically speaking
when drones cost 1.7 billion I'm not
gonna get a single one more than I need
all right I'm gonna get you there and
boom I certainly updated my twitch
stream elves in a relationship I don't
want to be bothered changing it back so
let's just make it official all right
hell yeah a thousand games yeah that
seems about right all right cool we're
good here so I'm gonna leave this lie
and I'll be back once I have an answer
to this conundrum which I don't okay all
right we are in a pretty good place
everything is at level 40 I don't know
how much I'm gonna need but given that
Ichiban was obtained at level 33 I think
this is going to be a good start for us
so I'm actually gonna take these away
because I need to focus on the money no
sorry no yeah I need to focus on the
money we need to get this this is this
this we needed all of these really okay
it doesn't matter
first off you Demetri are about to turn
into a regular old human a human and
luckily I always carry around mints for
just this occasion I've carried them for
many years
today they fill their destiny you've
never kissed anyone before all right aha
if a curse can be broken with a kiss
then prepare to end all the chaos in the
world for our co2 eternity kiss me you
fool I don't like you I don't know if
I've liked anyone here hey em once more
more man than beasts and unlike Beauty
and the Beast the transformation is a
mark of the improvement are you telling
me that you like mr. beast man in beast
mode that's new how's it going dear
friend have you cursed anyone else
recently yeah that would be so you I've
recently learned that boyfriend it's not
just a friend who was a boy which is
embarrassing for that it's what Kara
calls his boyfriends but Garret is your
boyfriend yes Garret Rick you you said
he is your boyfriend no take-backsies
[Music]
have strangers to where bail and get
nose piercing is good idea five billion
five billion hearts five billion how
much the game's cost all right whatever
that's not the point we're not here for
that
we are not here for any of that I have a
bad feeling that I'm not gonna have as
much as I need where's my super clicker
I can't believe it's been three days
since I started this adventure but it
has been three days I can't fathom that
like but we're almost here oh you
bastard you ain't a duck you ain't one
of the duck O's why oh you bastard but
look at those muscles don't look at me
like that I have no idea where that
ducky win I'm innocent I tell ya okay
all right
are you done yet how long is this curse
gonna last
is there a progress bar or something I
can watch all right all right okay I can
do this just got to get my game face on
come on Ichiban you got this one day
while walking through a very familiar
park each bunt race you and says hey I
just wanted to say that you're you're
right sorry
give me the kid memes and references
when I'm nervous anyway yeah well you're
great we're friends great oh god I hit
bird like I caught it and ate it
wait you didn't turn anyone into a bird
did you you need 10,000 rollers that's
fine
expectedly cheap man thanks this is nice
but it's not million subscriber nice you
talking about me I'm getting to the
bottom of the mystery finally I'm
getting to the bottom of the mystery
this is what I was here the mystery here
are you me are you give me a hand I'm
trying to come up with cute Tiger puns
for my channel how does this sound paw
that Bell and subscribe right meow
delete your channel okay never mind I
was sort of on the kiddie train at the
start but with all the internet points
but the whole litter box thing yeah
I could [ __ ] in a box big whiner
gosh this whole thing sounds like the
plot of some ridiculous anime clicker
dating game the only thing I hate more
than those are meta humor jokes in case
you can't tell I'm not a happy camper
my tail thumping around is a clue
although it's mega cute and I want to
bite it
ow God I just ruined another Mouse I
just can't help it
I've put my little paw in there and the
next thing I know I've wrestled it to
the ground and scratched it with my back
feet on the plus side I'm adorable that
does sound like me
okay that's another one for the sounds
like me column donut say I just noticed
you have an attractive personality and a
face that's nice to look at good job on
that well that was the most awkward
compliment ever I'm glad no one else
heard it let's pretend like it never
happened
tell me still a kitty still obsessively
watching my ceiling fan I can't blame
him being a kitty for that one bow
that's on me wow that went fast to get
to 3 billion I never noticed but most
console controllers are really hard to
use when you don't have thumbs huh
actually I think I just realized why
I've never realized that before purring
makes me giggle and giggling makes me /
what's the opposite of a vicious cycle a
snuggly cycle is that a thing God just
go away
I don't care if you are me at this point
just shut up ah I just knocked my webcam
off my desk again why do I keep doing
that that's something I do cue the
comedic Lee timed camera falling off my
desk bye everybody
overlays fire fireworks I knew it
okay it's not quite me but the hello
everybody is pretty damning there Suzy
Chiba hi hello everybody this is
markiplier it's the most damning piece
of evidence I have found yet I can't
believe this I figured this whole
transformed you know I'm not over that
you've stepped too far beyond the line
how dare you I figured this all
transformed into a tiger thing was gonna
make my life more challenging but my
subscriber count has exploded and the
number of cuddles I get per day is up to
I'm good if our little escapade here was
a video game I'm pretty sure I'd be the
king of it oh is that a crown I thought
so anger compilation wait a minute anger
compilations anger compilation you are
the king it's time to get to the bottom
of this to solve this once and for all
we must oh that's pretty cute please
don't tell anyone I was a scaredy cat on
that ride I've got a reputation to
uphold
I'm supposed to be the king of those
rides you keep saying that that's what I
say
turn you the squirrels taking five
nights of phrase with that suspiciously
like so wait a second you're saying that
to break the curse we've got to try
kissing but that's where cooties come
from that's what I say all the time I
say that all the time just kidding
in case you couldn't tell I'm an awkward
individual that uses humor as a coping
mechanism pucker up buttercup that's
what I always say I think that's me
so we got to make with the smoochy
smoochy ease that's what I always say
awesome give me a big kiss or ooh that's
what I always say one awkward and fuzzy
kiss later the tiger explodes into the
usual magic Sparkle transformation
sequence my nickname in high school was
Marco sparkle
besides the ears that is 127,000 percent
cue the dramatic music 120,000 % movie
you thought you could get away with it
you thought that you could trick me oh
no I knew I knew even though I could
have looked at the picture on the front
of the screen
I know rain Hellfire down upon you three
days I've taken to get to this point and
I am NOT gonna squander the opportunity
of you being right here you have to say
for yourself I would probably separate
no because I don't like that kind of
negativity in my alphabet mm-hmm is that
your impression of me that sounds like
you know that Bud Light commercial that
was like let's remove know from your
vocabulary and it was horrible and no
one thought it through that's what that
reminds me well I will say that if the
remaining Kitty parts need to stick
around at least just the kawaii stuff
well isn't too fond to the glans if you
catch my drift hey so I just wanted to
mention that Wikipedia has a lot of
unsettling information on cat privates
I'm happy to have a normal privates
again I felt that was worth mentioning I
live streamed myself eating a can of
tuna last night I have no idea why I did
it or why it's my most popular video now
cooky you think you're so clever
Wow you mostly broke the curse glad we
pounce on that ha ha we're play you
think you're so goddamn clever I will do
absolutely nothing I have no idea why I
put so much goddamn work and there's no
way in hell I'd ever get to that so that
just ain't happening so all you people
that were waiting for a picture of that
it ain't happening not happening don't
even try it it's not happening we ain't
having none
that but what we is having is we got to
the bottom in this mystery as much as we
could so that is good enough for me I
can't believe I spent three days on this
I have no idea what I did I put more
work into this video this one video than
I ever have in any other video related
to gaming so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you find me in any other
video game I don't know about which in
this case I think I think in general
consensus we have determined that yeah
that that's me you can tell by the
bulging biceps and sweet shoulders but
err yeah
that's me so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you endured this
adventure with me thank you and
congratulate yourself you made it to the
bottom this you persevered through thick
and thin you stuck it out and it was a
long journey but you were there for the
whole way so I thank you for that if you
had a like button I'd be smacking it
right now if you had a bell I'd be
dingaling in that Bell don't make a joke
about the cat in the Bell like I don't
want to hear it but you deserve the
appreciation I'm giving you and you
should be happy about the praise I'm
awarding to you so you're welcome and
thank you and thank you for watching if
you want to see other dating videos that
I've done let me know maybe I'll do it
or you want to see other you I'm tired
if you want to see me do more dating or
other things that I've done check
description or tell me but thank you so
much ring that Bell
smash that sub flagyl that like it it
all wit up in here thanks for watching
and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
Lexia and this is just for you and me
I'm going to put money into this I don't
wanna count on you not to let anybody
know about this definitely don't put
this at the end of the video after I've
already said goodbye just don't tell
anybody about this is just between you
good alright I have the money so now I
need to get this and I need two more
diamonds
I need more more more diamonds Wow thank
you for buying those you're incredible I
didn't buy anything I don't know what
you're talking about I didn't do
anything I have no idea what you're
talking about
I don't know who you are please get out
of my house oh hell yeah I'll give me
those sweet time slots a heli a village
elder oh my god now finally I can do
what I've always meant to do everyone
hush don't you why am I even talking at
it but there's no one here obviously
okay this is good okay now that I got
that I'm skip seven-day time skip
[Music]
Oh pill pusher push my pills please
[Laughter]
[Music]
anytime and now I have it and I feel so
good we're going on a masquerade och3
diamonds I cannot [ __ ] believe boy
indeed just take my money
hi I hate it hate it
zoom I hate it I'm knocking him out I
can't believe it
I'm knocking him out all I had to do is
wait a week Wow nice hit I can't believe
it
I'm knocking it out there we go do not
ask not that you even know what I'm
doing
do not ask why because that I didn't do
this from the get-go it's because I
didn't want to reward them not that I'm
rewarding him now because it's I'm very
upset about it look I got no
justification for it oh my god oh my god
dear lover I regret to tell you that I
must leave the world calls to me and I
must do if on the winds like a faith or
coffee energy I her just kidding I will
see you tomorrow for smooches and bon
squeezes all right you want a piano get
your piano piano think of all the kisses
you have to come I'll tell you what
kisses a lot yet to come
now you listen here you son of a [ __ ]
you thought I was done with you you
thought I was done with you I am not
done with you it is you who is done with
me
wait let her get a bell smash yeah gosh
I just cannot stop fluffing this tail I
think it's a good thing most people
don't have one of these it's distracting
all the fan art I have received recently
has become significantly cuter also
significantly more NSFW the years really
are a turn-on for some people hey hi
oh wait before you break the curse I've
got to record myself doing the caramel
car caramelldansen mustn't let the
internet down every time I look at your
face I get a stomach full of butterflies
does that make us sweethearts I mean the
other sweethearts or I've got the plague
or something so let's think
optimistically and say it's a sweetheart
thing hey I was just thinking in there
you're pretty like neato like super
pretty neato awesome cool hot words I'm
not saying you need to scratch behind my
ears but let's just say I would love to
be I would be your love slave forever if
you did oh yeah Oh
click the link on my face for more huh
loops I mistook real life for the
internet again let me just hit that 5
bonus right give this conversation
another try that is the stupidest thing
I've ever heard in my life live stream
our date and take suggestions from fans
on what I should say next just kidding
that was a nightmare last night that
sounds like a fun video actually there's
a good that's a good idea you know all
this is is just Stockholm Syndrome
that's all this is nice I love this as
much as a dating sim boyfriend can love
a thing and the Carnaval hey so
boyfriend scale of 1 to 10 how much is
that a thing with that we are boom 10
way to go Ichiban I mean your answer is
acceptable let us update this social
medias oh no ok here we go this is it
this is it this is it this is it that's
not so bad
not as bad as I thought hey I know
you're thinking Ichiban fell down in his
clothes fell off no that's not what
happened how did all this on purpose and
I have no idea how to flirt without
making things awkward
hence here's to more awkward shirtless
adventurers right hello this is little
old me doing little old things on this
little old day holy crap I just
irritated myself hey you're dead me too
I'm just gonna finish this out because
my goodness
hello everybody my name is Ichiban and
welcome to your fancy romantic date I'll
be playing the part of the love interest
let's get started that is that's me it's
me it's clearly me it's clearly be
alright yes so lovely you're special to
me and I want you to know it so I made
you an enormous heart-shaped card and
hid it somewhere unfortunately I forgot
what that was the point is I love you
you're awesome
no there's many other men I'm sorry I'm
very sorry you're the best I feel super
comfortable to be myself around you I
hope you feel the same because being
himself Ichiban is about 50% more
ridiculous than what you see on camera
I'll sponsor your episode anytime
internet lingo isn't the best for
flirting I meant to say I like you and
want to do stuff to your body well there
we have it it only cost me a hundred
bucks I hate myself I did it now you all
have that as a wallpaper
I'm gonna go crawl and die but the moral
of the story is if I'm a character in a
video game which obviously this isn't
exactly me the resemblance is striking
the quotes are very similar the
achievement refers to King a lot and the
hair is a slight nuance impression of my
previous colored hair doesn't mean that
there needs to be an issue with it
however your
and now that we've gotten to the bottom
of this mystery I think we all learned a
valuable lesson and if you don't know
what that lesson is then you weren't
paying attention so you got to go back
okay goodbye I've already said my
goodbyes goodbye goodbye
smash that like button smash it smash it
yes I'd like them
[Music]
you